welcome everybody how we're feeling now
we can pumped are you pumped yeah he's
pumped up that's what I like to hear
so this tour is about substitute testing
for data scientist the reason I put
advanced so advanced is always going to
be subjective but we're going to go
beyond a simple I cert equal we're going
to see what after that so that's why
it's gonna be a little bit more advanced
so before we kick off we have a nice
little team today so we have a David
hello the event is a senior Teaching
Fellow Kamri spark then we have Kevin
Kevin is the CTO of cameras lock and you
can see we all look completely different
in those pictures than what we look
today because those photos were taken a
long time ago especially you Kevin you
look really young I'm cool so what are
we going to do in this tutorial what
we're going to answer different
questions so the first one is is my code
correct that's a good start and that's
what unit tests are for then the next
question is well how do we write good
test then actually it's quite boring to
write test you know you have to write
all those assertions you have to set
things up would be nice if we could get
tests generated for us so we're going to
look at that and you'll see that it's
actually not that easy to do and can be
inconvenient and then finally we look at
the real-world situations where in
practice we depend on databases we
depends on rest ap is that we have to
plug into how does that impact our
testing so those are the range of topics
that will be covered in this tutorial so
there is a bit of a set up to do and
I'll walk you through the outline so
we'll kind of motivate the need for
testing for data sites after all testing
was created for software development so
why should we care as data scientist
about testing then a quick review of the
testing
available setting the scene then we'll
dip dive into unit testing using PI test
which is one of the tools available
we'll talk about why it's good for data
science in particular we'll talk about
writing good test what are patterns
available and then we'll look at
something that sounds really great for
dinner parties property based testing
and then test doubles and mocking so
it's quite a meteor agenda today so this
is the setup for today if you've just
arrived please take a photo of this
slide so you can do it I'm gonna leave
it up for 30 seconds and then I'll move
on so it's about I think 80 100 Meg's so
you know it's call of people in this
room we'll see how the network goes but
that contains essentially all the files
they'll be using this tutorial for the
demos there's a series of exercises as
well there's a notebook and there's some
data sets so that's why it's taking a
bit of space cool alright let's let's go
through so what's the background so
we're gonna look at a data set made out
of Kickstarter campaigns and we're going
to build a model around it so
Kickstarter campaign essentially is a
way to crowd fund a project and a
project might have different features
like the amount to raise the category of
the project which region this project
started in right so those features and
we'd like to build a model that's going
to predict whether a Kickstarter
campaign is successful or not okay so
we're going to write a bunch of code to
do the modeling and that's gonna create
a question and well how do I test this
whole thing cool so I'm gonna jump into
[Music]
Nobuko so once you've downloaded the git
repository you should say something
similar to that and we have a notebook
which I'm just gonna kick off will zoom
in so what you'll see is that we've got
a zip that contains a bunch of data I'm
gonna get pandas to load this up and
then we can get a feel for what the data
is and what you'll see in this data
there's different columns so there is
the photo for the campaign there's the
name of the project there's the goal so
that's the amount to raise there's a
bunch of interesting feature like the
country the the currency then the
deadline so that's a timestamp on when
the campaign is gonna close when the
campaign was created when I was actually
launched when the the post was created
and then a bunch of Jason kind of data
that represents further information like
the category the URL bugger an image and
so on right so this is the real deal
this is not like a made-up CSV file with
numbers this is a data frame that
contains text in Jason and we're gonna
have to build a model processor and test
it okay cool so that's the scene so what
you can do in the comment line so you
provided with a script called run dot pi
and you can run it and by providing the
argument train essentially what it's
going to do is to train the model on the
training set using believe logistic
regression and then it's going to
serialize this model into a job Lib file
ok so just to give you a flavor of how
things are structured here so I've got a
model this is the implementation of my
model okay it's a class
it's gonna create so hopefully who came
to Kevin's tutorial earlier yeah great
so Kevin did a fantastic job at
explaining how to psyche learn to build
a modular pipeline of a series of
transformers which can reuse so those
transformers might be doing some feature
extraction they might take some JSON
data and extract for example the
category or they might be doing some
translation between the the country to
its region so that's all the code is
being set up so that's my pre-processing
step and then training model logistic
regression and then I can predict okay
so that's the the code for the model
it's available in the model dot PI file
ok now as you can see all of this code
heavily makes use of different
pre-processing steps so there is a
categories extract country transformers
what's all of this stuff how do we know
this is correct is it doing the right
thing
so in this tutorial we're going to look
at well how do we unit test it all so if
we look at one of those categories
extractors what you'll see is that we
have a module called transformers which
capsulate all the Transformers that my
model is going to use the benefit of
doing this is that if we have a team of
data scientists they can already use
transformers that they've created they
can experiment with different models but
we get a benefit of code reusability so
that's why all those transformers are
packaged up into a module and what
you'll see the code is not exactly a
trivial there is some business logic
there's some pausing we're creating some
data frames we're extracting different
index so it raises the question on is
this correct okay so that's the scene
that's the background the structure of
the files and now we're going to look at
what we can do we've all of that cool so
testing for date designs
so first we talk about testing what is
it we want to test there's so many
things we could test so on one side
you've got a difference between
functional and non-functional
requirements functional requirements are
simply is it doing the right
functionality given input is it
producing the output I'm expecting right
so for example there's my model output
prediction in the expected range you
know is that two categories is it ten
categories if we have a finite set of
outputs is it actually producing a
result in this output so that's a purely
functional requirement the next question
you might be wondering well I've written
all this code that's going to do some
pre-processing it's going to take this
JSON object extract different attributes
may be converted do 100 coding all of
that so we have complicated business
logic that we want to test so that's the
functional part now we also need to
worry about non-functional requirements
it's we no longer live in the days where
we have a Python notebook and dot
predict something happens what happens
to the model we need to package it it's
going to be served by some sort of an
endpoint right so is my model when it's
deployed can it handle requests can it
cope to a thousand requests per minute
is there sort of SLA when I'm asking for
a request do I get a response within a
certain amount of time and for example
the classic scenario fraud detection
delays are going to be important we want
to detect the fraud right now not in ten
minutes time so those are non-functional
requirements and because data science
has become complex and more and more
specialized then we have different
specialized skill set handling those
different requirements so non-functional
typically would set with the data
engineering team as opposed to the data
science team now on top of that you
might have other concern so it's not
just weather is it doing the right thing
or not how well is it performing so when
you get push and you test your model do
you have a performance improvement in
comparison to any previous iteration of
your model can we detect those changes
what sort of test dataset did we test on
is that going to have an impact on the
performance so those are series of
questions that we need to ask ourselves
now that we're dealing with this piece
of code that will be deployed in
production so in this tutorial I'm gonna
focus on functional requirements and
functional testing does this look
familiar to anybody so why are we
testing well there's different reasons
why we want to test but one of them is
we want to avoid this right we want to
avoid a catastrophic failure in
production right so who works in a
financial service here right if suddenly
the transaction processing fails it's
going to be a love and happy people are
there so we want to avoid that right so
testing is about giving confidence that
we've got a correct implementation and
building confidence means that we hope
to avoid the scenarios where something
will fail now unfortunately things are
really complicated okay
so again in past data science was all
hot it's still hot there's kind of more
academic let's get a Python notebook
it's great pandas boom predict then what
today it's looking like that so I
haven't I didn't make this diagram
there's actually this was produced by a
team at Microsoft and a leading
conference on software engineering so a
software engineering conference is not
talking about data science so that's
quite cool and instead actually the the
data science workflow has becoming
increasingly complicated and there's
multiple steps involved so there is well
the data that's just one step you know
what data do we have where is it stored
what's the process to collect it is in
different formats we've got Chaser and
we've got CSV we've got pickle fires
we've got job Lib files we've got Park
Hae so what's going on there so there's
a dedicated team and specialists are
handling just data collection right
there's multiple database technologies
that allow you to store different data
formats with different trade
now what about the cleaning step you
know data is messy there is unknown
values the schema might be completely
messy we might not have everything we
want so who is responsible for the
cleaning part then if we are to do any
sort of machine learning then there is
labeling of the data this feature
engineering what are features of
interest your business domain which is
going to have an impact on the Moodle
training so that's Python code that
we're gonna have to write presumably we
have to test it right because it's going
to be complex business logic and only
then does the training come in on like
let's apply some fancy model let's
evaluate it learn from that and then go
back to the feature engineering step
maybe get the stakeholders involved to
collect more requirements and so on once
you've done that well it's on your
computer how do we deploy this as an
application for users then we need to
worry about cloud services you need to
worry about how to wrap this up into
HTTP endpoints where is it going to live
how do we test that who's got ownership
of it and then we need to monitor the
request
what sort of requests are users making
what's the output of the model once it's
deployed how do we evaluate that and
learn from it so the data science
workflow is really complex and what's
happening is that each of these modules
is a series of software and code that we
need to test those matching functional
requirements to build confidence that we
have the right implementation now on top
of everything I've said we have to deal
with dependencies we have to deal with
libraries that we're going to package in
in the application those will have
different versions then I have different
behaviors there's backward compatibility
issues we have to deal with web api s--
so live system that we're using which
you have no control on those behaviors
might change databases and cloud
services so there's a ton of complexity
from his data set to a model that is
deployed in production and that makes a
life a lot harder as data scientist
it comes to proving that our work is
functionally correct so the challenges
I'm sorry I said many different data
formats software developers are used to
collections list numbers classes and
objects right those are simple to unit
tests it's a well known problem and data
science suddenly we have to deal with
pandas dataframes JSON objects which may
have missing attributes and so on so
that puts challenging in terms of unit
testing we have to work with database
and web api so those are dependencies in
our code and those dependencies might
have different outputs depending on
which day we run the code so that's
gonna have an impact we're dealing more
with blackbox models so typically
something like a neural net
it looks like it's performing well it's
got lots of parameters but I have no
idea of its internal implementation so
when it comes to unit testing we have
this removed from us we don't have
knowledge of its implementation is
really where to kind of do blackbox
testing so the best we can do when it
comes to those models is testing ranges
because given an input the output might
be non-deterministic or it might be in
some sort of range so that kind of
changes how we have to test now because
the data science workflow is so complex
that means there needs to be enhanced
collaborations with different specialist
data scientists and data engineers have
to work together so that means we have
to worry about code maintenance code
modularity could reuse api's to kind of
facilitate productivity so those are new
challenges yeah it's no longer a
notebook it's now deployed in production
for people to use no worries this is
fine everything is burning it's okay
we're going to look at a series of tools
that hopefully are going to be helpful
to kind of go towards the path of
functional correctness so why a software
testing - to summarize maybe the least
interesting one you know fine bugs of
course that's something that we
want to have this maybe situation we
haven't thought of we might write a test
case for it and that's going to
highlight an issue in the code which we
can correct okay so that's kind of bugs
in the implementation more importantly
it's about removing the fear of changes
so doing like regression testing let's
say you have a fully implement working
model and pre-processing pipeline if you
make change to it how do you know the
behavior is preserved you haven't
introduced a new bug so testing allows
to remove the fear of introducing
changes it enhances debugging process
instead of having a big fat exception in
your console well now we're going to
have some interesting assertions going
to tell us in which scenario things are
working or failing so that kind of help
us in terms finding the root of the
problem and Jenny it's about increasing
confidence before we deploy into
production so that's why software
testing is important for the data
science workflow so let's review the
tools available in in person before we
focus on PI tests and hypotheses so
there is something called doc test has
anyone heard of doc text it's really
cute it sounds cute it's pretty useless
I think because it sounds good right so
you have we all care about documentation
we've always been told documentation is
really important you know I'm going to
look up a function and it tells me what
it's meant to do the parameters words
returns that's important pilot is gonna
flag it up if you don't have your doc
string on top of that you can include
the thing I've bolded so using the how
do you call this symbol the great song
let's go for the great sign three great
signs and then is basically Python code
and just below is the output we expect
when this function is executed okay
so a duck test essentially allows you to
test you're almost kind of testing your
documentation you have the unit tests
within the documentation so this is kind
of a helpful example to see potentially
how this function is intended to be used
okay so it's useful right you look at it
like well here's an example of how to
use this API on top of that it acts as a
test so test is embedded in the
documentation and really the purpose of
that is only to validate doctor
mutation it's not to validate
correctness it's not about being
comprehensive about all the scenarios
that we want to test it's just an
example so this is not a tool for
functional requirements testing this is
just documentation and there's no
natural fit we've a continuous
integration or coaches deployment
pipeline it's basically code that's
mixed into documentation and it doesn't
test all the test cases so that's not
really a tool that we should care about
as data centers however there is another
package called unit test which is part
of the standard library so raise your
hand if someone's using tests expect
quite a few of you yeah perfect allows
you to do unit testing in Python and
it's really popular with developers
because the whole philosophy of unit
test and the API wasn't designed for
parsing it was designed for object
oriented languages like Java Java has a
library called J unit which is classes
based with methods decorators and so on
that's where the API comes from so unit
test has an ope API so that means
there's more boilerplate you have to
define a test case it's subclasses test
case you introduce methods then you put
assertions the way you put assertion is
again a method so this is not as
convenient for data scientist that comes
from our Python background where you use
two series of functions so that's what
unit test is less popular in the data
science ecosystem perhaps more popular
in the software development system where
developers are used to using things like
Java Scala and C++ I have an Opie API so
it's more bullet plate and there is
limited diagnostics in terms of e
assertions available in the intestine
package now PI test is the cool kid in
Python so it's designed for Python so
what I means is simple functions you
don't have classes you don't have
methods you don't have 20 different
assertions as message it's just a
function call so it's got a low bullet
plate which is what we like
we don't want to spend a lot of time
writing stuff it's Python it's got to be
simple and then there's a couple of
really interesting of features which are
easy to use they're also available in
unit tests but there's more bulla pit
okay so one of those features
parameterize test so that's the
situation where you test one input and
output but the template of the test it's
going to be the same so in practice you
might copy-paste the same test and
change the inputs and output you expect
right parameterize testing we'll cover
down in this tutorial what allows you to
do is to abstract what's being tested
and inject the inputs and output you
expect so allows you to reduce code
verbosity and improve code maintenance
and finally there's fixtures so that's
the idea of decoupling data from from
your test or an environment so sometimes
you may have to plug in into a database
so you want to have some sort of setup
that is available to all your tests and
then you want to tear it down and close
the connection to your database PI test
makes that quite quite important it's
quite an advanced feature and Pam tries
testing use fixtures and we looking at
so let's take a let's do a quick demo
just make sure it runs through the same
page before we look at more advanced
things so and the list of files you
provided what you'll see is that they're
series of exercises that we're going to
look through and then there's different
tests so I'm going to look at unit tests
first of all so this is how I specify
the unit tests using the interest
library everybody's familiar with that
before you tell me a role you should use
assertions for pandas I know we'll cover
that so basically you specify a class
you subclass it you define a method and
then you specify assertions using assert
echo which is a method available as part
of test case class okay so when I do
that I can run this unit test okay great
so let's use the so if you want to run
all the unit tests available in project
you can just pass the unit test command
what it's going to do is to
run all my tests including the unit test
case here so what I'm going to do now is
to introduce a failing test so here's
another test just to show you what an
assertion failure looks like so I'm
going to unit test my country transform
that takes the pandas dataframe and it's
sort of output that we want to to expect
so in this case what we expect is the
output to be SI which is not gonna be
correct but let's let's run this and
what you'll see this is an example of a
failure that's produced so in this case
here
Europe is now equals to s a so Belgium
the region for Belgium is Europe and we
expected si obviously this is just for a
demo point of view
so my permutation is correct the unit
test is wrong but you see an example of
a test failure so how does that compare
to PI test so here's an example using PI
test immediately you can see you know
we've removed the bullet play there's no
classes there's no methods and there's a
simple function called assert that we
can be using and I can introduce a
failing test so really simple to write
and when we run that in the command line
what we'll see is also a test failure so
in this case I'm expecting the result to
be other but we have none that is
produced so let's dig through here and
what we might want to say is fill in a
and then other cool so I'll rectify the
implementation then we'll run a test
again and now all my unit tests are
passing okay so using my unit test in PI
test I highlighted a scenario where my
implementation was incorrect a fixed
implementation I run the test
I know it's passive ok so the main point
here is PI test there's low code
boilerplate and that's why it's really
attractive for data scientists awesome
so let's do some more interesting stuff
so we're gonna dig down into PI tests
and I'm gonna get you guys to write your
patter so here's an example of a
directory structure so that's my
preferred approach my background is more
from Java and software development where
is the area of separating out the source
code versus the test because when you
come to packaging and deployment all
your source files are available in one
directory that makes the packaging
process really simple now I'm not a
strategy that people tend to use is to
have your test module available together
with the module in the same directory
right so my have my transform is PI
module and the same directory and I have
the test transform the PI module ok if
we have that that makes it simple from a
import point of view because when you
run your test the module is readily
available in the same directory so
that's great there's no magic required
for importing but it makes the work of a
packaging the application more difficult
because you have to extract what source
code what's not and deploy that so I
prefer to separate them out and decouple
them so quick exercise just make sure
everyone's in the same mindset so in
this exercise what if God is so this
exercise called test exercise 1 but PI
and in this exercise what we want to do
is to unit test a transformer so the
transformer is a categories extractor
and what you'll see now is some decent
pieces of code right so it's taking a
JSON string as an argument
it's pausing it it's extracting the
attribute called slug you doing some
splitting it's going to do some
validation and then returning a panda's
data frame so what I want you guys to
think about here is you know first write
a PI test for for this this method so
I'll give maybe 3 minutes and we'll put
your everyone to make sure they come to
a PI test
so to recap the PI test what you need is
essentially you just write a function
and then you specify your assertion
using assert now if you want to run it
in the comment line you can use the
argument called exercises and what
exercise is going to do is to run all
the unit tests in the exercises folder
ok so if I run this well you'll see that
some things are failing some things are
passing because they're not yet
implemented so yeah cool
so give you guys about five minutes
right one unit test using PI test for
this exercise and then we'll work
through it together
instead of five minutes I'm gonna do
three minutes I've been told by my team
that I should hurry up
good stuff in the interest of time and
I'm happy to publish the solutions I'll
get push the solution after the talk
I'll just walk you through sample
solution why so quick of course your
forward so I've got a JSON string here
which is what is getting passed by my
transformer it's expecting a attribute
slug and then some sort of categories
and the schema for the categories that
you have the main category a slash and
then subcategories right and I'm going
to call the method and then I'm
expecting the result to be a list that
contains games and playing cards so
those to fix that's what the transformer
does so cool it's if I want to run a
unit test if use an ID like pycharm like
myself you can run it straight from the
IDE otherwise in the common line Python
ruin and then exercises so who's use PI
test before ah
so maybe half and then everybody's
unitized okay cool so this is a simple
example of how to use PI test now I'm
going to carry on because I really want
to go into the you know more interesting
topics so the first thing is pandas so
far my extract categories function was
returning a list that's easy that's
supported by PI test the assert function
can compare into an equality test with a
list well with pandas things are
slightly different right so let's let's
look at an example where I've got a test
oh and what I'm going to do so it's in
this code we basically are going to unit
test the time transformer the time
transformer takes a panda's data frame
it's going to extract different columns
multiplied by some sort of adjustments
let's go do some business logic to find
out how many days do we have in between
the the deadline timestamp and the
launch time step okay so those are
numbers we want to extract the number of
days and that number of days is going to
be a feature in my model okay how many
days were available for the whole
campaign so I want a unit test that is
this transformer are correct so I've
created pandas dataframe here which is a
sample data so that's the input I know
what the expected output is and I just
want to assert that the left-hand side
is so what we expect is the same as the
result okay so that's what we might wish
to write in PI test so far so good so
let's let's run that
boom what we'll see is that the output
is not particularly useful so what we
get is a fat extraction saying the value
a true value of the data frame is
ambiguous so we essentially using a
panda's data frame in a boolean
expression context and as a result of
that the diagnostic produced in the
console is meaningless I have no idea
what's wrong what's going on so to
prevent that and I'm gonna make this
test fail again so let's just run this
yep so you'll see it blows up I have no
idea what the bug is I have no idea
what's the difference in the expected
end result now pandas supports a testing
package and as asset frame equal is as
it seriously call is asset index equal
that allows you to do accurate equality
test on data frame or series so this
function scores set free miko so if i
use that and run my unit test again what
we'll see is that we get something a
little bit more useful basically we get
a nice trace that says the values are
different the left side we've got 29 the
right side 129 so now actually i get in
a day of what the the problem might be
or what the source of the issue is okay
so let's let's fix this test and now if
I run it again we'll see everything it's
going to pass so what's the story here
is that as a data scientist you use
pandas pandas is our favorite library
right there is specialized assertions
that you can use that gives you
meaningful Diagnostics ok so if you
didn't know about them then you now do
and encourage you to you to use them to
check that your data frames are correct
cool so the next topic is parameterize
test so it can be quite repetitive to
try for different inputs and check for
the the same outputs right so for
example here
I've basically checked one input if I
were to check four different cases maybe
the deadline is zero the times time is
zero
you know if I'm paid by lines of code
this is beautiful
I can just copy that you know put zeros
zeros and then zeros and zeros and test
runs formula zero timestamp actually
I've no idea what that's going to be
cool
Yolo cool well something's right in the
code it's good stuff but you see now if
I have to come up with yet another
scenario that we want to test again
after you introduce lots of code
replications so parameterize testing is
the solution to that it's really that
clearly there is a template here right
so there is this sort of setup with the
inputs I had some sort of basic
transformation then there was a step
where I'm doing invoking different
functions and they're my assertions the
whole thing can be Prime tries with the
input and output I want to check so
rather than use code duplication we can
create a template and then pass on the
inputs and outputs so that's what Pam
tries testing is let me show you how it
looks like in PI test whoo isn't that
sexy for she we're going to make less
money because these few lines of code
but it's more maintainable so everyone's
going to be happier so let me explain a
little bit what's happening so the first
thing you'll notice is that I've created
a list here with the different scenarios
that I want to test for this list
contains tuples okay so you recognize
the triples with the nice little parent
sees now a tuple basically has the input
as the left-hand side and the expected
output as the right-hand side okay so
what we can essentially do is to each
rate through each element in that list
and we have the input and expected
output
so that's the set apart so that's nice
because you may collect those
requirements from the business right the
business might tell you giving the same
point that's the output I'm expecting
that's great
you cannot translate those requirements
into a simple Python code and it comes
the dark magic so the dark magic is this
part so that's using a decorator so a
language feature in Python and what this
decorator says is first so this is the
awkward part
you have to provide a string and this
string is essentially the list of
parameters that are going to be mapped
to the input and output okay so that is
applied to each tuple in the list okay
so clearly we've got a sample data frame
and we've got the expected data frame
great and that's the list that we're
passing so know what PI test is going to
do there's some clever stuff going on
it's going to say great now I can inject
each sample data frame in each expected
data frame for all your test cases so
sample DF is going to be mapped to to
this in the first run and it's going to
be mapped to that in the second run it's
going to be mapped to that in this third
one and the same thing with the output
so now so let's just let's run that in
the IDE see what's over result we get
cout and you can see there's three tests
now passed right and the reason it's
three tests is because there's three
scenarios that I'm testing out so
parameterize test allows you to be more
productive focus on their business
requirements and translate that into
code yeah
correct yes so you basically have your
list of variables in the string and
that's being mapped onto your function
definition but in your tuple size needs
to be obviously like the same cool so
perfect rise test encourage you to use
it it's a great tool for writing
momentum will test the slides has
exactly the same code snippet so I've
done this demo so there is another
exercise let's look at this together so
in this exercise what we want to do is
to write some comet rice test for the
time transformer which is exactly what I
was demoing so let me show you the
sample solution so again here I'm
basically setting up my test cases
there's a list of tuples each tuple
contains the pandas dataframe with the
different inputs that i want to test and
you'll recognize the zero zero that was
kind of testing earlier and I'm setting
up the data so that's the part where you
actually need to to think more right so
what are the different scenarios that I
want to check correctness for and that's
a painful part because you consciously
think what all the possibilities where
things are going to go wrong and in a
bit I'm going to talk about generative
tests to kind of go around this issue
and the template part is the easiest
part right so once you know what the
template is I've got a time transformer
I want to apply processing and then I'm
basically going to do an assert that the
two pandas dataframe or equal okay so
let's let's run that and what we'll see
is that two tests were passed because
I've got two samples and testing out
four okay so you can combine parameters
tests and the pandas assertions okay all
those things can come together awesome
cool so we've learned about Patos basics
we've learned about PI test parameters
tests we learn about pandas assertions
which are absolutely vital when it comes
to data science now how do you write
good tests you know we can go crazy
let's write tests for everything it's
gonna be great but like what makes a
good test so the first thing there is a
simple pattern which allows you to
structure you test essentially what it
makes your test is bit more readable
more recognizable that's called a given
when then pattern so it's not a design
pattern like you know structuring
software classes it's just a skeleton to
recognize the behavior of test so
there's the given step which is your
preconditions so those are the inputs
are you setting up there's the wind step
there's the behavior you trigger for
example I'm calling the transformer and
the den step is what is it we want to
assert on so here is a test that follows
the given when then pattern so I've got
my set up some nice space saying it's
obvious I've got the part where we're
playing behavior I can immediately
recognize that just by looking out and
then what is it we want to verify okay
so what it means your colleagues when
they look at your test they'll like you
because I blow you this is really simple
to understand I know what's going on
okay so that's a good pattern to to
follow for readability and code
maintenance now there's a ton of
libraries that allows you to write more
declarative tests so that's basically
attempting at bridging the gap between
the business language and the code okay
so I cert being a and seeing a and Len
equals two is very Python you need to be
a programmer so someone with more of a
business background if they look at that
because they might be involved in the
requirement phase and the test that
might not necessarily be like able to
understand what's going on Excel get
bogged down on syntax now what assertion
libraries and PI truth is one assertion
library developed by
Google that turn a bridging the gap so
another way to write this would be to
say I said that a contains exactly B and
C and keep in mind here we've not
specified the order right so C and B my
opinion if you order so we just care
that they are contained in to this list
okay so here's a bunch of examples of
assertions available in pay truth yeah
it's like at least over a hundred
assertions available so I'm not going to
cover them all I'm encourage you to look
at this project especially if like I'm
saying the business uses are involving
the requirements in the testing part
then that can be a helpful way to close
the vocab r-e for example you can say
something like I'm expecting a string to
start with the character a so that's
like writing English or unless has a
specific length or something is on zero
so let's look at a quick demo of that so
in the notebook I've got proof available
here so let's I've loaded everything
cool so I'm going to take the first row
this is a panda's data frame and I'm
basically gonna set up some assertions
on that so to give you an idea I want to
write that the deadline is non-0 great
that's passing who is you available yeah
so what that says here and you know not
true that this number is zero okay so
there's also enhanced Diagnostics that's
what's really helpful so when things
fail there's a meaningful error message
that kind of tells you what's going on
so that's specifically useful if you
know you've adopted continuous
integration you get push you get a
report from your server then you have
like nice you know error messages that
you can quickly pass now let's look at a
third example searching that the blurb
contains the word songs and that's
passing if I were saying blow actually
let's see nope it's failing and the sort
of diagnostic that is generated is the
text here original songs and music
videos to jumpstart the
Hawaii comb will tow chef's container
would love and it's not so we get an
assertion error
okay so pate roof is maintained by
Google so that's a project to to to look
at cool so on top of that so given wind
and paddlin allows you to structure the
test pi troof allows you to write more
declarative tests that bridge the gap
between the the business of camera in
the code but how do you write
maintainable tests the top of all of
that so tests are just code
it's just Python at the end of the day
so we should treat it like Python code
for what it is so here's an example of a
bad test who likes this test okay no one
cool it's good stuff so what's bad about
it yeah one what is it
yeah test one means nothing right so if
the test fails in the console you see
test one error what's that supposed to
mean yeah magic numbers magic rebels
what's five what's one zero I have no
idea what are we trying to achieve here
and yet I did go so yeah it sucks and
there's most of their sucking which I'll
explain a bit but here's a an example of
a good test okay we're not optimizing
for number of characters guys okay we're
optimizing for reading the test you
wrote at once it might be read a hundred
times
so let's optimize for the read okay so
nice meaningful test case name just like
the gentleman with a nice beard said
right it has that model predicts
correctly with some standard input great
the construct of the predictive model
let's use named arguments fix PC say
what is it we're trying to do or maybe I
should even extract five as a constant
of variable say what it is
I've got input features a nice variable
names we're following the given wind and
pattern and more subtly this assertion
self I said true the only fee that's
going to do is to tell you that the
boolean expression given as an argument
is true or false but I want to know
what's going on what number did we get
how we're comparing against the output
right so this diagnostic is gonna be
meaningless she's gonna be true or false
what we want is well you want to tend
where you go 12 or you got 11 so there's
an off by one error somewhere so I can
go back in my code and see what were the
issues right so thankfully with PI test
you should use assert you get out of the
box so that's another reason why you can
ditch unit test and use PI test right
because using one function you get all
those enhanced Diagnostics
out-of-the-box
so what are the best practices so
verbose naming is better you want to
test the behavior not the implementation
so in the example I had I was actually
accessing an internal field to check the
state of my model so if that changes
over time
with some refactoring my tests are going
to be refracted to so you wanna make
sure you test the API so that the
internal implementation can freely
change and you test is still working so
that's good don't repeat yourself so
good duplication and so on parameterize
test is the solution for that go now
another tool that the software
development ecosystem has been using is
test coverage I want to be a little
careful about encouraging getting 100% I
definitely encourage getting the green
bar you know you want your tests to be
passing you don't want failing test for
sure but what test coverage allows you
to determine is the lines in your code
that were not executed when you run your
test okay so like potentially is useful
to detect things that you're not testing
but it doesn't mean you've actually
tested all the scenarios for different
behaviors just mean those lines of code
where we're not executed okay
so it's just an indication so it's
typically integrated as part of a
continuous integration pipeline right
because if you got zero coverage that
sucks really but you don't necessarily
mean at 100%
you want to kind of get indication wise
potentially not test it or test it so
there is a project called practiced
curve which is a plugin that integrates
with pi test it's going to give you some
indication of what you're doing so I'll
show you in the comment line what it
looks like so I can run my coverage here
if I run that what you'll see is this
kind of output so my model dot pi which
is here the lines one to 62
nothing's tested and that's because I
didn't write any unit tests for my model
right so I could have written a test for
example on the predict a method is it in
the expected range I didn't do it now my
transformers you can see there's
different parts which I'm not testing so
clearly between 63
74 something is going on so let's see
what I tested so we'll go to transformer
between cool yeah so that's the time
transformer so this is the code that I
was testing and I showed you a demo
earlier that was ready interest with
time transform so that's been picked up
but everything else has not been tested
okay so that is kind of a useful report
that you can take and then write more
unit tests to increase the coverage but
again it's not indication that your code
is fully correct because you might still
be having all your lines of code
executed but there might be certain
inputs that trigger different behavior
cool so the next exercise is about
refactoring a unit test so let's say
I've got a test that is written like
that then how would you go about
refactoring this test so clearly we can
use a panel assertions so let's jump
through a solution so this is a test as
better structured tree separating out
what's the preconditions what's the code
that we want to apply and test and then
what are the assertions okay now on top
of this hair we could have used the
third frame eCos rather than kind of
manually extract the different bits and
bobs and do an equality on that okay
cool ah let's go to a something really
fancy which I've got my doubts on how
practical and useful it can be so that's
kind of controversial but I did find a
bug in my code by running hypothesis so
actually there's credit here the reason
I'm giving a big caveat I don't want
everybody to embark on the buzzword
bandwagon property based testing that's
all adopted it's not that trivial so so
far everything I've shown you was it's
called manual testing I have to come up
with scenarios that I want to test
against so I'm testing for specific
inputs and specific outputs so that's
easy to write you know PI test boom
given when then assert it's all great
it's data Minister given an input I know
exactly what the output is it's great it
runs fast right because simple function
to execute so unit tests are meant to be
executed fast because when I make
changes in my code I merely want to know
some sort of regression report where I
want to know what's gone wrong I don't
want to wait ten minutes for the whole
thing to run and then have a cup of tea
and come back right I've got a momentum
I want to fix it now there's a massive
downside the downside is if you think
about the the integer space that's an
infinite domain unless we think about it
ain't like it's 32 bits int right but
there's so many numbers available we're
going to test for one so it's not really
representative of the state space
available when I write a specific test
there might be things I'm missing out
and typically it's things like negative
numbers we always think about positive
numbers what if my data I'm reading from
an API produces a negative number which
might be an error code how is that going
to impact my implementation so we don't
really think about it's kind of stuff
right so because it's unnatural
so manual lots of pros is it set up but
might not be checking the full spectrum
of the space generative test is the idea
that unit tests are being created for
you the inputs are generated so you
don't have to worry about that oh that
sounds cool so the pros is that
potentially it's way more comprehensive
because we can navigate in search a
wider state space so that's a big
benefit with generative tests the big
cons is that it's harder to write so if
I give you guys a bunch of inputs you
don't know what the outputs are so
how can we write an assertion we can't
we can't say given X we expect why you
can't do that because you're generating
inputs you don't know what the outputs
are for those inputs right because you
want to test for it so conceptually it's
it's really difficult
it's non-deterministic so a generative
test depending on different runs might
generate different numbers so you're
only once you might say I just want a
hundred tests generated but what if your
state space is a billion you know you're
only going to get a subset of that the
next row and you're going to get another
subset of it so you have this
non-deterministic behavior which is
really annoying because if you think
about continuous integration you get
push you want to know exactly what's
going on if you get push the same code
you don't want to have different test
reports right that's just gonna you're
gonna go crazy you're not going to know
what's going on so we want deterministic
behaviors when we test and the other
downside is a lot slower right so if you
generate test well there's some
computation activity by default so it's
always gonna be slower I'm not saying
it's super slow I don't have a an
equation lab it's definitely slower than
running one test because you generate
stuff so that's the caveat so now I'm
going to look at generative testing a
little bit so the intuition is that
instead of providing specific inputs and
outputs you specify a range of inputs so
I want data frames with two columns that
have integers that's the range of inputs
now it can be any integer that's going
to be generated for us and you need to
specify a rule and the rule is like well
what is it we can check well I want to
check that any output I still have a
panda's data frame with two columns but
because I don't know what the correct
results are going to be I can specify a
property like I'm expecting all the
numbers to be positive that's a property
or I'm expecting the length of my data
frame to be two that's another property
that's an invariant that we expect which
we can specify but it's not asserting
specific input is getting a specific
result it's basically saying there's
sort of property which I'm expecting
always to be true and if you have that
the rule together with inputs are
generated then test cases can be
generated on the fly and that's the
premise for property based testing let's
look at an example so I'm using a
project called hypothesis which is an
open source and available there's quite
a lot of work going on at the moment
it's always moving rapidly so let me
explain these bits of code before I give
a demo so this decorator given is
provided by hypothesis and everything in
bold is what we call a strategy so you
need a strategy to generate inputs my
strategy here is I want to pandas
dataframe so there's a panda is
extension for hypothesis so that's good
I stated scientist we can use that and
it says I want a data frame with two
columns one called go one called static
USD rate and those two columns I'm
expecting floating-point numbers okay so
I've defined the range of the state
space definitely their frames always two
columns and the values of floating ports
now using PI tests beautiful features
then this is injected as the argument to
this function as a sample data frame so
what happens this is going to do is
generate random data frames that I have
two columns we're floating point numbers
and that gets passed to my unit test
every time it's generated okay so that's
how we generate test now the problem I
have is I don't know what the result is
going to be because I'm trying to test
the implementation right so the old best
thing I can do is to set up a property
so that's an invariant I'm expecting the
length of the sample they do frame those
generate the input to always be equal to
the result if somehow the result is
going to have three or four one or zero
columns then something's going wrong in
code somewhere right so that's an
example of a property so let's do a demo
and I'll show you how I actually found a
bug using this stuff so test transformer
hypothesis okay
well so first I'm going to run the
decoder I was showing to you so if I run
it from here where you'll see so let's
run this in your console so using one at
PI you can say hypothesis okay and what
you'll see let's just look at the output
before I go back to the code what it
says is that 100 passing examples zero
failing example and you know I
configured hypothesis to generate 100
examples you can configure that to a
thousand ten thousand if you want to Bob
viously that's going to slow down your
test okay
so what I was doing is to essentially
check for the name now I might want to
do something slightly different
now I'm going to set up a different
property I'm gonna set up a property
that expects the adjusted goal to be
greater than zero right so when the pan
is their friend ran by hypothesis get
pushed down into the transformer here
we'll get a result I want to check that
that result I'm expecting is going to be
elements greater than zero so now if I
ran hypotheses what we'll see is that
there's some weights in arrows that I
have not been tested in this case here
find an assertion error that if the
input is 0 and then infinity we've got
some issues let's let's run this again I
wanted to find me the negative numbers
okay so it's always producing the same
test case the reason is doing this is
when it's failing the first time and you
haven't fixed that it's got
check the failing test the first thing
for the next one so that's kind of a
smart way to check that you've corrected
that implementation now let's jump to a
better example so to do that I'm gonna
show you the source strategies that you
can create so at the end of the day this
is only going to be useful if we're able
to generate different inputs when it's
panels dataframe whether it's Jason
whether it's text whether it's integers
so using hypothesis I can import
strategies so in this case I'm going to
pour two strategies one called text that
allows me to generate arbitrary text one
co-list allows me to generate arbitrary
list with number of elements so this
could here since she says I want a list
of text okay please generate a bunch of
examples so if I run that we'll see
we've got some empty list are generated
and then it's going to do weird things
like different Unicode characters
because that's always going to create
some issue you don't do line if you
doing some decoding empty list or a list
with an empty string and so on right so
this is a strategy that allows me to
generate list events now perhaps more
interestingly when it comes to data
sciences we deal with data frames we
learn about doing assertions on their
frames so how do i generate them so this
is the data frame dies two columns and
above generating floats so if I run that
what you'll see is that it's generating
a data frame with two columns one row
with somewhere floating point number and
then another one and if I run this again
it's going to check for the nan
situation which potentially is gonna
break things somewhere right so those
are test cases that you want to make
sure your cost code is robust against
now my favorite and the reason is my
favorite is in practice you have to deal
with JSON data right and JSON data is
typically a string they represent a sort
of nested dictionaries so how can we
generate nested dictionaries that's the
real deal right so there is a shortage
Rico fixed dictionary which I'm going to
input and what that takes as an argument
is the structure of your expected
dictionary this dictionary is simple it
has one key called slug okay and the
value is text okay so further on that
you'll see that it's gonna generate some
random stuff every time which is great
because this is the hard stuff that we
never think about so now I've got a tool
that generate all those inputs and when
you Barros deploy in production there'll
be some smartass that's gonna you know
try and call your predict and point with
some weird characters right so you wanna
make sure you test against that so I'll
use this example in a bit for the demo
but another one that a particular ID is
the regex so you can generate text from
a regular expression so for example here
I want to say a string that starts with
a B and C and this true character long
so return my wound
it was ABBA I'm a favorite music band
just kidding
cool so you see it generates text that
fits the regular expression so that's
quite handy as well especially if you've
got some understanding of what data you
expecting there's a structure to it now
you can't combine the whole thing right
so for example I can combine the regex
strategy inside the dictionary strategy
which is part of a list strategy so I
can generate a list of dictionaries that
following regexes so all that stuff is
really composable so that's really the
power of hypothesis so for example here
I'm going to generate a dictionary which
that's because I'm gonna import JSON
right so what it's doing is to generate
some dictionary that follows this recipe
so the recipe says you need a key called
data the value is going to be generated
from this regex that produces strategy
and map and filter are available in
hypothesis so that allows you to do
transformation on your strategy or
further filter on the strategy right so
for example what I'm saying here is
giving the strategy that generates
dictionaries I want to generate adjacent
string from that so I'm calling map and
pressing J's and dumps and I'm
generating an example so each example is
a string there is a JSON object right so
this one line of code generate inputs
there are JSON object represent as a
string which follow a specific schema so
that's really powerful so how do we do
how do we use all of these stuff so I've
given a couple examples of how to
generate input so you can do it through
values so things like integer text and
boolean you can strategies for
collections like dictionary lists map
and filter are available so that's for
example if you're generating numbers and
you want to filter out the range of the
numbers or there's some sort of property
I want to filter on that can be useful
there you can generate your own strategy
by implementing an interface in
hypothesis right so that's all possible
so the prologue of generating input is
solved the huge problem that is left is
how do we specify properties right
because conceptually that's difficult
so here's what the community has come up
with when it comes to specifying
properties so you can specify things
like invariants so if you know that the
result is going to have a specific shape
certain number of columns for example
that's an invalid that's something you
know is not going to change you're not
testing the output you're testing a
property ok the size of a collection
you're expecting a list to always be of
size 3 when you pass it to a
pre-processing function you can test on
that you contest on the result of the
list but you can test the property for
example you expect all the values
generator to be positive or negative or
in some sort of threshold you can do
that
so that's invariance those conceptually
a finger fairly simple and you can
specify them right now where things get
a bit more difficult is when we want to
do useful stuff
so there's another class of properties
called round trips so that's typically
when you have two methods that work
together so if you insert an element
into a list of you insert something
database there's probably another method
available that's going to check for
containment right so you can specify a
property that says when I insert
something I'm expecting it to be
available so those two methods work
together and the JSON example lo jason
loads and jason dumps work together
right so if i encode and decode
something i'm expecting the same input
so that's a property if i reverse
something twice i'm expecting the same
input so that's what we can specify but
you see conceptually it's not really
business logic it's kind of thinking
about some properties in contract that's
why it's difficult to adopt a tool like
that now wonder is simple though is does
not crash so that's basically you call a
function and you accept you expect no
exceptions to be thrown and a classic
example is if you try to do max on a
list if the list is empty what do you
think is going to happen value error
it's not possible to find a maximum so
in this empty right it's impossible you
need at least one element find a maximum
so those are things that we don't think
about
so hypothesis will generate empty lists
and then you're saying when I call this
code I'm expecting no exceptions to be
thrown but with the empty list something
would be thrown so that's a different
kind of property now one that can be
useful if you know what you're doing
it's called the Oracle test so let's say
you're testing the implementation for
your code where there's an alternative
implementation that you know is correct
that act as your Oracle right so give an
input you can pass it to your function
you can pass it to this magic Oracle is
always correct and then you can compare
the result of those two so that's the
closest to doing classical assertions
and an example that is brought up you
know in the communities
14 right there's a built-in sorting
function in PI state we hope it's
correct right so if you give an input
and you sort it you'll get a result if
you've written a new salt you can test
the output using this Oracle that we
know is already correctly implemented so
that's possible but having those fully
working implementation is not always
available so that works when you have an
interface and maybe you're coming up
with a more optimized version of the
same algorithm then you can use the less
optimized one as the Oracle all right so
that's actually where you can use
property based testing and you'll find
problems in the implementation right so
let me show you the bug that I found in
my code which I'd never thought about so
that's quite interesting experience for
me it was quite enlightening so I want
to test my categories extracted so let's
go to the categories extractor and show
you the problem cool right so here's the
categories extractor okay what it does
it takes a JSON string and the JSON
string is like this right so it's going
to have something called slug and then
it's going to have web and then Python
okay that's the input what I want as a
result is web and Python
sounds simple right so I've written some
code for that all right well this is the
code right it looks it's basically it
pauses the string in Jason gets the slug
and if the string is empty we have a
default which is a slash and then we
split on that okay so if the string is
empty we'll get to empty categories
produced yeah so first of it so let's
write a test for it so
using hypotheses who spoil alert so this
is my test right so what I've done is
create a strategy that generates a fixed
dictionary using slug from regex so
that's the string with the slash and
thumbs down into Jason so I get a string
sounds good right so far so good and
then the property dumb I'm expecting is
you know the list should always return
to elements because there is the main
category in the sub category cool so
let's run that woo nightmare
what's gone wrong well so let me run
that in the actually I'm gonna copy that
in here
and then we'll get something a little
nicer cool so what happens if we get
this kind of input
can you run see I never thought of that
what if we ever double slash and the
value for the slug my code is returning
a list with three elements when we have
that right so that's the situation you
never think about and the reason what we
have done is if I go back to the
implementation we are splitting on the
slash and there's two of them so we get
three elements I was not expecting that
so this is an example of some data that
I structured in a way that I would never
have thought we would get but the regex
says you splitted by one slash now if I
fix the code which is right so what I
need to do is to say max plate by one so
if we overload the version of split
essentially what I'm saying is split the
first time you see a slash and that's
the tail we no longer pass the tail
because in the tail there is another
slash that we would split on otherwise
and that's what's generating three
elements as opposed to two okay so if I
refractor the implementation I would say
split on the first slash and that's it
then I can run the test again and what
we'll see is that it's passing so this
is another test is failing somewhere
else but let's let's run it from the
solution right so that's kind of really
subtle scenario where hypothesis was
actually quite helpful for me to
to detect a bug cool so how much time I
ever got left
Oh perfect ten more minutes so a related
topic to property based testing and the
bigger picture is we have those kind of
contracts that we want to check against
a static type checking so that's also a
property because we say we expect a
value to be an integer who expect to
value to be a stranger to be a list now
if you know where this project it's good
one to check let's call my PI dad's
static type checking to pison so when
you say a function have a string and can
return the string then my PI will try
and detect those errors before you run
your code right so that's another form
to do testing not on behavior
implementation bond types and values
okay that's cool project to look at
unfortunately it's pretty limited right
now to things like collections less than
values there isn't support yet for
pandas so you can't specify type
signature for pandas dataframe with two
columns and floats and get static type
checking you can't do that
but there's progress for numpy there's
an experimental project that is adding
support for type checking to things like
a numpy array so you might want to say
this temp array has a D type of integer
our to detect that before I execute the
code so there is ongoing work so that's
looking good for us hopefully over the
next you know I don't fix months or
years there's more and more code
checking tools available in the Python
ecosystem alright final topic of today
it's called knocking and a waste how
much ah how much who's this guy I
actually don't know what what's his name
who knows what his name is do you guys
stretch him back huh which one do
the one on the left they could look
quite similar no day well I don't know
but this is the concept of a double
right so when you're in a dangerous
situation that might impact your health
what do you do you call a double that's
going to take the risk for you right so
double is someone that replaces you for
a specific situation can we have doubles
for testing yes we can
why would we want to have doubles for
testing here is this situation
you followed good code practices using
saccular and transformers and pipeline
and you've extractor your processing
steps it's amazing it looks good
awesome however as I explained at the
being of the presentation the data
science workflow is really complicated
we'll have so many dependencies
databases api's cloud services so your
code is very likely calling a live
system somewhere that's returning a
result that potentially is helpful for
your pre-processing so in this case hey
maybe I'm loading something from AWS
okay so I've got a dependency to the AWS
client in my code and now I'm going to
try and test process data well how do I
test it because every time I call this
code it's calling freaking AWS buckets
every time so we're in the situation
where in order to test the code I
somehow need to kill this dependency or
replace it with something I can control
because the live system depending on
where the wind is blowing might have a
different output depending on the day so
how do we get predictability when we
have dependencies on life systems that's
the problem that knocking and test
double is solving so there's other
issues right if I call a REST API
difference output but it might be down
the server might be out of service that
means my test is going to fail that
means your CI system is going to fail
there's fire everywhere
now clearly connecting to an endpoint or
a service is slow right because maybe
a call over the network so we're paying
some latency cost which goes against the
principle of unit testing we want to get
failures fast so lose all the series of
issues with unit testing when we have to
deal with dependencies which is the real
world that we have in the data sense
work flow so what's the solution a test
double so it's essentially an object
that has exactly the same interface as
your dependency though you control it
and you can say what you want it to
return or how do you want it to behave
so it's a way to replace the dependency
with something you have control over and
the benefits is that it's fast and you
have predictability so the attorneys
always deterministic now before I show
demo it's a big topic so different
popular libraries would provide you with
testing suites which would implement
doubles samoto its testing library for
Bato which is the way to interface with
AWS so essentially all the different
servers like connecting to s3 there is a
double that doesn't actually connect to
AWS the returns the pre can result but
it's got a same interface PostgreSQL
provides you with an in-memory database
which you can setup and teardown for the
tests so you don't actually have to
connect to a live database and flask you
know if you implement endpoints for your
models would provide you a test client
that is now actually making requests in
a server ok it's all encapsulated cool
so here's an example of how to set up a
mock in Python and then I'll show you a
demo so let's say I've got this
preprocessor object and this
preprocessor has a dependency to a Dao
right so a data access object so
something that interface with a database
I don't know what these databases but
I've got an interface for it right so
that's the benefit of the deal now the
problem is the dao connects to your life
system so i want to kill the dependency
and control it so you create a magic
mark I know it sounds fancy that's how
it's called and what you can do now is
well whenever some code somewhere calls
the method
or the function in this case called load
data I want to control the return value
that's something I am setting so I get
predictability and the return value is
going to be data okay so what it does is
whenever load data is called his pre
kind information we no longer need to
connect with the live system and what
you can do with Marx is to specify
assertions for example this function was
called once so that allows you to verify
interaction with your code okay so
there's many assertions available you
can check how many times a function is
called where it's once or multiple times
with specific arguments or whether it's
not cool right so that's what a mocking
framework will allow you to specify so
that's for verifying interaction now the
other side you can also control the
return value or for example a specific
exception dice draw so those are the two
features available
so let's look through an example so what
you'll see is that I've got a
transformer here which is an OD
transformer so transformer that is
actually connecting to a REST API so
it's passing the country and as an
argument
it's parsing the result from Jason and
then it's returning the region so for
example for Canada it's going to work
for CA it's going to produce Canada for
B e it's gonna return Europe okay the
region where the country is associated
so I've got an implementation here which
is hard coded unfortunately it doesn't
scale to every country it exists in the
world so I've decided to have my
transformer using API the problem I've
got now is when I run a unit test I'm
depending on the API which might be rate
limited so my tests are going to be
flaky so using a mock what we can do is
to say I've got my country transformer
whenever this function is I called the
get region from code here's a mock I'm
going to specify a side-effect so a
side-effect here allows me to return an
iterable
so that means every time the function is
called we iterate through those values
if you have one you use return value
which is what I had in the slide if you
have to call this function multiple
times and you want a different result to
be produced every time it's called your
side effect any trouble okay so the
first time it's invoked it's gonna
return Canada the second time it's
invoked it's going to return you can
i'll it okay so I'm creating my
partner's data frame which has country
and two elements transforming it and now
what I can check is that this function
get region from code was actually called
and it's called within the transformer
somewhere when the processing is
happening so what I can do now is thanks
to this mark verified that the correct
interaction is happening under the hood
we were depending on a life system okay
so let's let's ruin this and what you'll
see is that the unit test is passing the
implementation is correct and if I dig
down to my transformer Y you'll see it's
happening is actually simple
implementation I use map and map is
iterating over all the elements in data
frame and to do that it needs to call
get region from code and that's where my
assertion comes in to say it's been
called twice with different outlets okay
start smoking in a nacho so really
useful technique to essentially
substitute dependencies to life system
of something can control and get
predictability on whoa alright so thanks
for coming to my tutorial so we're gonna
have a move tomorrow on Saturday and
Sunday come say hi and thanks for coming
[Applause]
solutions in one of the breaks so you
can download them and do the exercise in
your own time as well